north korea is famous for creating a
cult of personality around the leaders
of the country and kim jong-un is no
exception
for his entire time as the supreme
leader of north korea kim jong-un
appeared on camera a lot public
addresses threatening nuclear war and
military parades were part of his
everyday schedule
but then in april 2020 kim jong-un
suddenly vanishes from public view
where is north korean leader kim jong-un
but something someone was missing
kim jong-un by studying satellite images
north korean state-run media north
korean military parades and tracking
flights in and out of the country
intelligence analysts were able to
determine that kim jong-un was indeed in
hiding
this got analysts wondering was the most
dangerous leader of the east ill or
maybe even dead
and then suddenly someone emerges in his
footsteps to watch the throne a woman
named kim yo-jong kim jong-un's sister
she's very well educated involved in
politics and took over many of kim's
duties while he was missing but don't
let her small frame saw face and smile
fool you if she takes her brother's
place as the supreme leader of north
korea she will most likely be way more
ruthless than her brother ever was
if her past has anything to go by
so if kim jong-un does die you should
probably get to know a little bit about
the future face of north korea
kim yo-jong
[Music]
[Applause]
the last three supreme leaders of north
korea were men so why her
to understand that we have to take a
look at the kim dynasty kim jong-un has
at least four brothers and sisters but
most of them aren't exactly great
options for taking over north korea
there's kim jong-nam his oldest
half-brother who was first in line to
take over the country until he got
caught trying to sneak into tokyo
disneyland with a fake passport to which
he got exiled by his dad and eventually
assassinated on his brother's orders in
2017 literally real life godfather stuff
then there's kim seoul song his older
half-sister who was very active in
politics and said to be her dad's
favorite unfortunately it wasn't a great
time for women in north korea when her
father died so she got overlooked
because of her gender the next best
option would be kim jong-un's other
brother kim jong-chul except he's more
interested in guitars eric clapton and
becoming the north korean hugh hefner
then taking on the moral responsibility
of being the supreme leader so he's out
too kim jong-un's kids can't take over
for him they're still too young so that
just leaves kim jong-un's younger sister
kim yo-jong
[Music]
kim's sister was lucky enough to be sent
to a prestigious swiss school to get a
first class education unfortunately the
majority of us aren't as lucky as kim's
sister but thanks to the internet we can
learn practically anything a prestigious
school can teach you all online that's
what i did and what i still do to this
day and that's where skillshare comes in
skillshare is an online community with
thousands of classes that help you learn
skills that you're passionate about one
great option is the productivity master
class principles and tools to boost your
productivity it's made by the youtuber
ali abdull and can help you unlock your
productivity potential by understanding
how productivity is affected by your
mindset and habits
forget boring lectures and homework
everything you learn here is easy to
digest relevant and actually applicable
to your career skillshare is always
launching new classes there are never
annoying ads that interrupt your
learning so you're definitely going to
be able to find a ton of classes that
speak to you plus the first 1 000 people
who sign up with the link below will get
a one month free trial of skillshare so
you can start exploring your creativity
today seriously i would not be here if
it wasn't for self-education so that's
why i love sponsors like skillshare and
why you should click the link below to
get your one month free trial thanks to
skillshare for sponsoring this video
kim yo-jong is either 31 or 33 years old
depending on whether you asked the u.s
treasury or south korea when she was 9
her dad sent her and kim jong-un to
school in switzerland she enrolled under
the fake name pak mi huang their mother
was a concubine not an official wife so
he sent them a way to protect them from
the north korean elites and of course to
protect his reputation as a moral and
divine supreme leader
and in north korea in common society the
morality is very important if kim
jong-un shows to nursing people that he
had multiple wives he would not be good
mother so he had to hide his children
and that's why they went to study in
sweden for that reason so the two kims
live with their aunt and uncle in
switzerland had their own private chef
and a team of bodyguards to look after
them when kim yo-jong finished school
instead of leaning into more of modern
society in the west she chose to go back
to pyongyang and join the kim il-sung
university she studied a special
computer science course that gave her a
degree in just six months no one really
knew or cared about who she was she
never appeared on tv and most people
didn't even know she existed until much
later by 2007 she joined the north
korean workers party working under her
aunt and learning how to manage north
korean politics
now she's working as a deputy director
in the korean workers party and in the
propaganda department but it wasn't
until 2011 at her father's funeral that
she was publicly seen and acknowledged
for the first time she made her first
official appearance in 2014 and this
innocent kind looking girl would soon
become the most ruthless woman in north
korea
[Music]
after appearing with her brother in 2014
kim yo-jong quickly showed that she was
ready to move out the ranks in the
regime when her brother got sick just a
few months later she easily took over
some of his duties around that time she
was also a deputy director at the
propaganda and agitation departments
which is basically in charge of making
the kim family look like gods she also
managed all of kim jong-un's events and
security she became his right-hand woman
as close as you can get to the supreme
leader what's even more interesting is
that over the years many analysts have
come to suspect that she's the real
brains behind the regime her brother
just has to put on a smile and do as she
says
ever since 2014 she's in the background
of almost every public appearance her
brother makes
kim yo-jong might be the one pulling the
strings behind the hermit kingdom
[Music]
kim yo-jong has been getting closer and
closer to power in north korea in 2017
she became the second woman ever to be
promoted to north korea's politburo
their inner political circle
she also married the son of the nominal
head of states the guy in charge of the
army and the second most powerful man in
north korea
according to the intelligence oscar they
have two children first born was in 2015
and second born in 2018. she attended
the south korean winter olympics in 2018
becoming the first north korean
politician to step foot on the other
side since the korean war but when she
got there people immediately noticed
something was off about her appearance
the kim family is genetically fat but
she's extremely thin pale and always
looks a little bit ill her complexion
and behavior brought south korean
doctors to suggest she's probably on
meth
so when she visited south korea around
2018
the experts in south korea were saying
her look her complexion
shows that she was using a lot of
crystal meth drug and it wouldn't make
sense north korea produces and exports
huge amounts of drugs like crystal meth
to keep the money flowing into their
coffers so her being addicted to the
stuff doesn't seem so far-fetched at the
time she says she looked sick because
she was pregnant but her looks haven't
changed ever since
and if having a sober dictator in north
korea is terrifying just imagine what a
dictator hopped up on meth would be like
back to her visit kim yo-jong talked a
big game about fighting common ground
with south korea when she visited but
then just a few years after she got back
south korean activists started sending
massive amounts of anti-kim propaganda
over the border using balloons she
immediately released a statement calling
south korea's president insane for
allowing them to do that she threatened
to destroy the inter-korean liaison
office that was supposed to keep the
communication between the two sides open
and a day later the building was blown
up apparently when kim yo-jong orders
something north korea obeys
and recently she's been speaking out on
her own a lot more calling south korea a
frightened dog barking for complaining
about missile tests she's becoming even
more aggressive than her brother
[Applause]
before she could take the throne kim
jong-un re-emerges he had lost a lot of
weight probably not in a healthy way and
analysts believe he's sick and that he
may even be preparing for his death kim
jong-u's time seems to be nearer and the
more we learn about his sister the more
it looks like she would rule with an
iron fist
the fact that she's a woman and that
most of the military leaders over there
are older than her only makes it worse
to get them to respect and fear her she
has no choice but to be as ruthless as
possible at least until the stone is
gets older enough kim miyazangana act as
a supreme leader so a lot of people say
because she's young western educated and
women
she must be a better leader
her record doesn't show
us that she's actually even brutal than
kim's own
she blows up
and she destroys things she even
threatened joe biden recently saying if
america wants to sleep in peace for the
coming four years it had better refrain
from causing a snake at his first step
so even though kim jong-un seems to be
okay for now his failing health can mean
that north korea will soon see its very
first female supreme leader and even if
it seems like a win for women the idea
of a die-hard dictator on meth was
something to prove in charge of the
fourth largest military in the world
with chemical and biological weapons and
an estimated 60 plus nuclear weapons
should give you a little pause
and by the way guys we have a private
documentary coming out soon on
everyone's favorite person every
jeffstein it would definitely get
demonetized if i published it so it's
only going to be available to members of
this channel and you can join by
clicking the join button below or using
the link below if you don't see the join
button this is where we reserve only the
best most controversial documentaries
that explore how the world really works
that can't be released to the public we
have a new one coming out every month
and you won't be able to see them
anywhere else click that join button
below for everything they would never
teach you in business school for a tiny
fraction of the price and if you join
and don't think it's worth it email me
and i will personally refund you the
money but i have a feeling that you
won't regret it
[Applause]
[Music]
you